because there's all these anti-vaxxers
now isn't it well marina can tell you a
little bit about how we've achieved
it's clear what the prime minister makes
of those against vaccines
many might agree but in the case for a
covid jab public perception really
matters
leah says she wouldn't have a
coronavirus vaccination she's vaccinated
her children
and herself in the past but she's
worried about the speed of development
this time
what makes me nervous is that it's being
pushed upon us and it's literally
like a ransom for our freedom that in
and of itself
is enough of a worry because if the
doctor said right okay heart disease is
just so horrific it's our worst killer
um you know the government have decided
we've now got to all take statins
i would say no i'm not doing that i
refuse to take a medical intervention
any kind of medical treatment
that i haven't fully researched myself
to decide whether i actually need to do
it that's the first and foremost thing
so why would you put something into your
body
without really knowing what's going to
happen to you a new poll shows
she's not alone just 53 of people said
they'd be certain or very likely to get
a vaccine against coronavirus
while one in six said they're unlikely
or definitely won't
and some groups are more skeptical than
others 37 percent of people who believe
face masks are bad for health
said they'd refuse one the under 35s
were twice as likely as the over 55s
to say they may not get one even within
families who would all choose to
vaccinate
the generational divide is a
consideration i would take it might not
want to take it in exactly the first
wave of
of taking the vaccine and but i can
understand who
young people who are getting this
disease not having many symptoms
i can see they might be a bit more
ambivalent the media is presented the
virus is something that is
less dangerous to younger people
so it gives an impression that you know
you're more immune to it but
i can see why but i'd also say it's
quite naive
okay the weight of science and history
says vaccines are
safe trials here at oxford university
have showed positive early results
there are currently no reasons to be
concerned
about the vaccinations that are being
developed for covid
they are undergoing intense scientific
scrutiny
both the oxford vaccination and the
imperial college vaccination
the data shows there's significant
crossover between those people who feel
the government reacted too
slowly to the pandemic and those who may
be reluctant to get a vaccine
it could be our ticket out of the crisis
but it needs public cooperation
and that needs trust communication will
be vital
people may well feel differently when a
vaccination is approved and widely used
but the race is on not just to make it
but to persuade people to take it
helen and smith sky news